thank you maurice yes i'm here with uh
wesley so one of the toughest
competitors uh
in uh the grand chester wesley first of
all welcome back to bucharest and
welcome back to the grand chess tour
uh tell us a little bit about how
different it is from the past this
tournament from the past one year and a
half
yeah thanks thanks first of all for
having me here christian uh thanks for
inviting me to broadcast to everyone
who made the granchester possible first
i'm very pleased that
granchester happened this year because
until two months ago i wasn't sure
if it was gonna happen because of kobe
and so i'm very glad to be here i mean i
haven't played overboard in 18 months
i've been playing very well online but
it's more speeches rapid than blitz
so i was very nervous coming before this
tournament
i mean things so far been doing okay
obviously
i don't like all these draws but in this
top level it's very difficult to win and
so far i haven't
made any major blunders yet so i think
things
have going been have been pretty pretty
interesting
and of course i'm glad to be back in the
circus tell us a little bit
more about those early draws because
we've seen a lot of them
in this tournament what's happening are
the players not used to uh
compete over the board anymore or what
yeah i mean
i i mean the game one i think there were
two or three more or less theoretical
draws but
i'm never going to criticize any of my
colleagues because i'm a player myself
and i know how
it's very difficult to be a top chess
player so i'm not exactly sure what's
going on in their mind for instance stay
more
he made a quick draw on the first game
i mean and also today he made a quick
draw by playing this rook b1 grunfeld
uh it seems like players are still
playing
online in the champions chess store
because this time with
rp1 actually i played this myself online
when i'm trying to draw to secure
qualifications
so i think i played this rook b1 grunt
field like eight times
or ten times and then i got like one win
in nine draws
so this line specifically is just a
fourth draw
uh the one between taymor and maxime so
i played this many times online not only
me but also many other players when
they're trying to draw with white
so again i'm not going to criticize or
question my colleague's decision
because they know much better than
ordinary people
but i'm just curious what's going on in
their mind
because if you waste your white games
then
your points could put pressure a lot of
pressure when you're black
but today my game with grishok was very
interesting
too i mean i thought he would go for 1v4
or 1c4
but he played this line in the in the
berlin
and uh after h2 and move 9 uh here i
play
uh three or four moves i play bishop d7
king e8 also bishop b7 i also played
knight e7
so i played bishop d7 in my last few
games online also against greece stroke
i think there's nothing wrong with nine
bishop d7 i made a draw with against him
but today i decided to play bishop e7 do
you feel this uh surprised him
on any level uh this bishop p7 move
instead of the
bishop d7 uh personally i i don't think
so because i played this also a few
times but i think i'm pretty sure on
mobe 9 he was expecting
more this bishop d7 because that's what
i played in my last two three games
but i'm sure he prepared this also but
of course
the berlin is very solid and then we
followed durie
until like move 918 again e7
so i think this has been played before
in some games or at least has been
analyzed extensively
k7 very accurate so the question of of
course is
if white has some practical chances to
win because he's basically upon up on
the king side
meanwhile i have my double c pawns so
practically speaking black has to defend
very accurately but objectively
position should be a draw of course here
rook d3 is probably slightly more
slightly more um
ambitious rookie one king f6 knight e4
in here
i think i'm thinking of seven before but
i think king g6
also uh could even be very slightly more
accurate
uh i see nothing wrong with kg6 i was
calculating
but i played king f7 just to see whether
he'll repeat
and he did repeat actually i he could
play rook e3 after
king f7 and we were just analyzing after
the game
the point is that after bishop f5 white
can play
rook e1 or you can play king h2 for
example
and then say the position after this
we're after trade trade
three three through the eighth so this i
think
similar end games like this has been
played as alex spritz chuck said he's
analyzed also these kinds of end games
before
but i think black should be able to hold
without
too much problems because white's
pawns on king's sides are not connected
uh
also after e3 bishop f5 maybe we could
try
rook ae1 because i probably wouldn't
play rook h8 because after
check takes this
this end game looks quite dangerous for
black
but bishop against knight definitely
something to play with
especially uh due to the fact that you
cannot create passport on queenside
yeah sure h4 f4 and maybe white can uh
have a slight advantage
but in the computer seems absolutely
nothing wrong with this
yeah yeah turkey even i was gonna play
some rook
and then king h2 yeah and maybe white is
a bit
better yeah so maybe after okay e1 white
has some very small practical chances so
i should play king g6 and move 20.
absolutely do you uh of course as a
player with black pieces it's very
difficult to create
any imbalances but do you feel taking
this type of early draws especially as a
player with
white could be a branding problem for
chess
uh yeah yeah of course i mean
chess is like one of the only sports
where a draw is
a tie the most common result i mean
supper you go for
overtime and all that that's why uh what
norway did braindressing where you had
armageddon
in in after the games and finna draw so
that could be very interesting
uh i mean chessy it's very difficult
because
you have engines very strong millions of
games
um there are computer games that players
follow so everything's very analyzed
almost all the way to their like even my
game today against mr
uh position after move 1819 has been
played
a few times already so that's uh
that's a problem like if you want to
play really objective chess the best
chess
unless most games end in draws and i
think
like 75 percent of chess games and
indoors especially in classical
so yeah obviously something has to
be done about that but
i think it's not just the players
responsibilities but also the
tournaments responsibilities like
changing roles or something or
organizers responsibilities because
the players want to play the best chess
and sometimes
you're just not gonna make too many
chances
and again i'm not sure what
my colleagues have in mind when they go
for quick draws with white
as um i'm sure they have a
good reason uh uh as grace troop said
the other day he
tend to start slow i think uh some
russians have that like alexander morsi
beach for example he
before very very good russian player
he tends to make a bad result in the
beginning but then he heats up towards
the end
so that's a very good reason of course
because sometimes a droisa is a very
good result already for
for everyone especially in this in this
level
perfect thank you for your insights
wesley always a pleasure to have you and
welcome back to bucharest thank you so
much